Oh
some people say oh because your work is
very common you know blah blah blah
therefore it's very Asian I think it's a
little bit maybe it's a little bit Pat
to say that as well I'm sure there's
something in there that's important but
i'm not sure what it is because who
knows what Singaporean is at the moment
I'm trained as an architect and in 2001
I made my business partner Benson saw
who is trained in product and furniture
design and a couple of years ago we
decided to put everything under one roof
so we do a variety of things we do
architecture we do interiors we do
products from furniture and lighting as
well what is interesting is also the
different disciplines kind of cross
influence each other what we're trying
to get to is this hybrid situation of
some somewhere between architecture and
product and furniture it's very much an
inbuilt intuition for for us I think you
know something feels right if I think we
will we will sort of somehow internally
know about it many a time we have to be
kind of I know psychoanalyst to some
degree because I think you have to read
your client you have to know where
they're coming from what the
commonalities are what the differences
are and you have to sort of strategize
accordingly I think most architects when
they progress in the career they want to
go bigger and bigger and I think for us
we've kind of gone the other way in
slightly because we've gone smaller and
smaller now looking back the couple of
kind of milestones when the lube lamp
was first produced I think that sort of
brought us from sort of experimental
kind of makers to to the world of
product design a lot of these products
are successful because they fit into the
interiors of the time and I think the
loop lamp you know fits in you know at
that particular moment in time there's
probably also the element of surprise
when you turn the top disc and it
reveals the light so I think there is an
element
surprise or surrealism they're
increasingly we we are starting with the
material and a process as a starting
point so the bone china collection was
the first because the bone china process
is very particular it is a back and
forth between a material what it can do
and the forms that you're trying to
impose on it the virgin upper class
cabin sort of again brought us to a new
kind of realm because you know that is
the realm of transport design and we
wanted to not just confine ourselves to
designing the cabin interior but also to
to come up with a strategy for the cabin
interior so we went back to basics and
we did a lot of research on what the
current thinking is about retail about
luxury and what a current thinking is
about travel as well so luxury traveler
didn't want just kind of to be pampered
by five starr you know luxury travel the
travel of today wanted things like
experience about sort of in a wantin to
be so challenged both intellectually and
emotionally it's also the the marriage
of architecture and product design that
where we've been trying to get to and i
think that is the sort of the archetypal
project for us i think good design first
of all marries all these kind of
different strands of you know
technicality functionality etc together
what makes good design great is
something that challenges what has gone
on before so it not only kind of answers
to brief but it's or questions brief as
well work hard that's my advice for
young designers
you